okay first of all you're a genius like
this whole thing is ingenious like how
did you come up with just getting people
on your show watching celebrities just
be like like burn their mouths how did
they agree to it I love it
well the real genius is my partner in
all this Chris Schoenberger and he runs
first we feast and he came up to me and
was like you know I have this idea what
if we were interviewing celebrities but
eating increasingly spicy like violently
hot chicken wings why the interview was
going on and the way it hit my ear it
was just like so funny to me that I'm
like alright let's get in a room and
sing this whole thing out shoot a pilot
and go like some of your most memorable
ones well there are a lot you know we've
done almost 200 episodes at this point
believe it or not but if I were to try
to get somebody into the show it's like
if you watch the Paul Rudd episode or
like the Gordon Ramsay or Charlize
Theron Scarlett Johansson if you like
those episodes you'll probably like the
show so those are the ones I recommend
so has anyone just ever just like passed
out vomited run to the bathroom like any
abuse check yeah we have like a whole
Royal Flush like a whole tic-tac-toe
game that we could oh my god it's like
who's gonna make it or what it's gonna I
always think like our first studio was
in kind of this office building and
around the studio would just be people
like on computers answering phones
you know returning emails and then like
very famous people would just come like
barreling out of the door where's the
restroom where's the restroom now it's
thought it would be like funny that they
must be like what do they do in here do
you know anybody that's done this show
and I know I mean I know Charlize I
haven't seen her episode though I'm
gonna have to check that one out classic
episode yeah you like you have a couple
of Oscar winners in there yeah do you
think celebs go because they feel
challenged like they're gonna conquer it
well I think it might be what I'm
thinking today
you know you probably are in that same
mindset where it's like I think if you
watch it there is part of you that
wonders could I handle that or how would
I how would I handle that spice so I
think there are people that you know
they're curious about it but I think the
thing is that we really try to extend
for our guests meet them halfway with
like a very thoughtful career-spanning
interview like yeah we want it to be the
most the most comfortable uncomfortable
interview is what we really try to do is
I think it's hard to keep a wall up when
you're like and I think there is
something about it that interrupts the
formality of it all you know like if
you're doing anything like even if
you're trying to like balance books in
your hand like maybe there is something
about that that takes your mind off of
the sort of interview into a realer
place yes so you're turning hot ones
into a game show which is brilliant like
[Applause]
a to wing like a giraffe eats like she
is that what is the game show like well
I think that if I were to try to connect
the two because they are very different
shows you know ones like a classic
interview show over spicy wings the
other classic game show over spicy wings
but the way that I think about it is the
appeal of the interview show is it takes
celebrity you know this thing that's
inherently by definition some sort of
like unobtainable lifestyle status and
then it takes that person down to a
level that everyone understands and then
the game show takes that person the
person watching and exalts them into a
hero status because they can conquer the
wings and then make it to the top of
this game show win $25,000 so that's
where I think that's where I think they
connect but otherwise like totally
different show and you folks at home can
play along to know if you can help
needle subscribe to my channel subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going